are you ready now to witness a power not
seen for thousands of years
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
now tell me that learning that you
pumped
[Music]
so I started working out when I was
really young I was actually about
thirteen or fourteen and by the time I
was fifteen I was actually quite strong
for fifteen year old which was weird but
I was a weird kid
then anyways I broke my wrist and my
arms in quite spectacular fashion and
within a cap the went from my wrist all
the way up to my shoulder probably meant
at stop training other meant I couldn't
get to school I was stuck at home on the
couch just lying there for hours at a
time pretty miserable really obviously
it sucks that I was losing muscle
quickly etc and had to find something to
do to pass the time and that's when I
discovered Dragon Ball Z on Toonami and
this is the perfect antidote for me to
watch because it was the show all about
guys building themselves up stronger
getting tougher all the time and facing
any challenge and that was one of the
things that got me through that long
stretch of boredom and was also one of
the things that motivated me to get back
on the horse as soon as I recovered get
back into training get stronger than
ever and then when I was 16 I won teen
body builder of the month on
bodybuilding.com so happy ending to that
story
so obviously Dragon Ball Z was quite
influential to me as a young kid getting
into training was also a big fan of to
martial arts at the time I did karate
capoeira and Tai Chi and it turns out
that a lot of other people were
similarly inspired to work out by Dragon
Ball Z if we take a look around YouTube
then lots of the big Fitness youtubers
similarly crediting Dragon Ball Z is one
of their biggest inspirations you've got
people like Goku flex actually built his
entire channel around the whole notion
that he's training to look like Goku and
he'll also actually achieving it his
body is and saying Congrats
then there's the awesome Jax blade who
commented on one of my videos so that
makes me a little bit famous
he often covers training programs
inspired by anime characters and just
take a look on Instagram you'll see
loads of workout channels posting
pictures of Vegeta and Goku training or
guys training in DS inspired by the show
it softly just a big thing especially in
the fitness community so I thought it'd
be fun to break down Dragon Ball Z and
see what it is that makes it such great
inspiration for people who lift weight
or do martial arts and at the same
maybe by doing that I could dive into a
little bit about why I'm inspired to
keep on training and maybe inspire you a
little bit as well you know so on the
face of it the most obvious reason that
Dragonball Z is great inspirations for
working out is the fact that it's all
about massively strong guy punching
seven shades of [ __ ] out of each other
like the guys are drawn to the
incredibly muscular curly well
proportioned they've got the physiques
of you know the best bodybuilders on the
planet and so anatomically correct just
looks awesome and just looking at that
is a great kind of aspirational physique
to gun for so that's the the obvious
thing and just watching those fights is
a great way to get yourself pumped I
think goes way beyond that there's a lot
more to it because as loads of shows
about big bus guys that have quite the
same cult appeal among fitness
enthusiasts so one of the things I think
that sets Dragon Ball Z apart is the
fact that it focuses on the training
actually shading these guys working out
to get stronger in the training methods
they use training in height and gravity
and hyperbolic time chamber students
particularly realistic you're not going
to get your training tips from Dragon
Ball Z but it's certainly cool to see
how they actually got those awesome
physique and to see them working harder
and getting stronger and constantly as
the show progresses you see the
character evolve and get stronger too
and this is one of the things you can
kind of aspire to as well and you can
think if I keep on training and if I
keep on putting in the effort that
they're demonstrating and I can also
continue to get stronger there's a very
competitive element in Dragon Ball Z as
well of the Goku and Vegeta in
particular the highly competitive with
each other always trying to get one up
on each other
the g2 is completely obsessed with being
the strongest guy on the planet in the
universe and he will stop at nothing to
keep getting stronger and keep beating
Goku Goku meanwhile just loves training
for the love of training I think these
are things that we can relate to if we
go to the gym often I mean a lot of
people will find they're motivated by
trying to boot their friend and get
stronger than them and I'm certainly
competitive with a few of my friend to
go to the gym and likewise I think a lot
of us can relate to Goku who just really
doesn't want to be doing anything other
than training like he's bored when he's
stuck in a suit when he's having to do
general work for chichi and I think for
a lot of us who loves the gyms we can
really relate to that because I
your boards duck cushion pencils when
really you'd be much happier if you
could be lifting weight and training and
doing what it is you like and I don't
even really know why it is the trading
so fun
but you know that's to be aggressive as
Goku demonstrates training is just fun
for the sake of it
yeah watching these guys train watching
them push each other further it gives
you a real sense of the kind of same
motivation you get in the gym and the
kind of camaraderie that maybe you have
with your training buddies and at the
same time it's great to see them always
training to overcome the next challenge
they're always working out harder and
pushing themselves further and that's
basically the crux is pretty much every
plot that Akira Toriyama
has ever written bad guy comes along
here is a two week to beat him they give
it a shot anyway
get beaten then they go away they get
stronger come back beat the bad guys
then the bad guys get stronger and beat
them again and then they get stronger be
him and eventually someone gets so
strong so they beat them and they stay
dead and can't regenerate from a single
self or whatever is so they can do they
it's all about rising to that next
challenge and pushing yourself further
and pushing yourself even further beyond
and this is what he's doing
and to go even further beyond
and that to me is what trading is all
about it's all about rising to the next
challenge getting stronger so you can
take on whatever life throws at you and
not even in the literal sense because in
Dragonball Z they can get stronger to
beat the enemy that's how it works but
in real life that's not really how it
works anymore unfortunately because most
the challenges we face will be financial
or career or relationships based and
getting stronger and stronger doesn't
really help you in any of those
situations cert is symbolic when you go
to the gym my way of saying I'm not
going to back down I'm not going to take
this lying down that's basically it's a
kind of defiant that's what working out
is to me it's my way of saying I'm never
going to give up I'm never going to give
an inch you know and a lot of people
will negations gym and they're feeling
low on inspiration and motivation what
they'll do is they'll self talk
themselves up and they'll say things
like I'm the best you know I can do this
you know
never surrender etc and they'll punch
the air and stuff what I sometimes like
to do do the opposite and go you know
what I'm too tired competing and
defeated this week has been too much you
know there's too much going on in my
life right now and then that always
gives me the inspiration I need to carry
on because when I get to that point that
I'm like no way am i giving up now I'm
going to train even harder and yeah
that's how it says it finds to me and
that's why I like it in shows like
Dragon Ball Z where you see the hero
he's beaten there's no way that they're
going to possibly do it and they're just
like you know what I'm going to do it
anyways and they just train even harder
and in Dragon Ball Z they really do
train harder they push themselves harder
and they shout at the top of their
voices and would it be cool if you can
really just solve all your problems by
just putting in pure effort and you can
see that effort on the screen when
they're trailing when they're fighting
and when they turn into a Super Saiyan
or an ultra Super Saiyan or a Super
Saiyan God Super Saiyan kaio-ken times
ten you know it's just this kind of
physical representation of the kind of
fighting spirit that you need to succeed
in everything and also particularly to
do well in the gym and this is where I
think the real genius Dragon Ball Z
comes across and I'm not even sure it's
intentional because I think that Super
Saiyan how
like this fantastic metaphors for human
will
so that might sound a bit grandiose for
a program that has you know talking cats
and things in it however he's bear with
me so Super Saiyan is unlocked in this
font to a need not a one having when
they're highly emotional and then you
have other transformations such as the
recent people say in rage that shrunk
stood and Gohan often raging out the
whole point is its emotion that fuels
the Super Saiyan transformation and
makes them stronger more powerful and
their hair spike on end and their body
pulsed with electricity and that's kind
of what happened with us as well as
human thought old it's not as cold as it
look as cool but I've spoken on this
channel before about muscle fiber
recruitment and about how you can only
access a certain amount of your
strengths about 30 to 50 percent 50% for
top level athletes percent for everyone
else when you lift the weight your brain
can only recruit a certain number of the
muscle fibers at once so the purposeful
limits on how much you can lift
however in extreme cases of urgency of
dire need you are able to recruit a
higher percentage of that muscle fiber
it can be done just by raising your
adrenaline and the more you raise your
adrenaline the greater the percentage of
the muscle fire but you can recruit this
is why you hear stories it's called
hysterical strength it's why hear
stories of mothers lifting cars off of
their children cats Annie that's why
hear stories about people going mad with
rage on the battlefield and going into
this kind of rage mode it's just when
you really need it it's there you know
and the rest of the time it has to be
locked away because otherwise you can
cause an injury to yourself it's cetera
but if we could tap into that full
potential just a little bit more by
having more of that dire need and more
will and control over our own body then
we could become much stronger and
studies show that even just shouting can
raise your adrenaline levels to the
point that you actually can lift heavier
weight just shouting having someone else
present and what the two stones do
they're shouting you know the shouting
what they can crack their muscle and
guess what happens when you raise
adrenaline high levels your hair stand
up on end
you know when you hear an inspiring
piece of music in your hair stand on end
that's adrenaline and that's the
fight-or-flight response so we can't
turn into Super Saiyan trust me I've
tried the hysterical strength and the
Caesar said have a lot in common
they both involved shouting they both
involved unlocking hidden potential
inside yourself and they both call your
hair to stand up on end so I just think
that the people saying is a kind of
perfect visual representation of the
will that you need to perform your very
best to lift your hardest e to defeat
any obstacle I think that's one of the
reasons that Dragon Ball Z speak to you
on like just more base level than it has
any right to because like I said
anything your Kiera Toriyama planned
earlier this and I'm probably meeting
way too much into it
but I think on some levels we probably
drew these characters and he was kind of
channeling that kind of sense of will
that you have when you just really need
to get something done and you're calling
upon every last ounce of strength today
I hope you found this interesting thanks
a ton for watching if you did find it
entertaining then please consider liking
or sharing it helps them out a great
deal and if you'd like to see more
content like this and training advice
and productivity and new trade pics and
neuroscience then subscribe and you'll
be able to see more down there maybe
considered following me on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram it'd be great to
catch up and answer questions on there
also I'm sharing most of my workouts now
you know a couple of shots from them on
Instagram so if you want to see that
then you can follow me there and yeah
I'll catching the next one so bye for
now
what did the scouter say about its power
level its over 9000 what 9000 there's no
way that could be right